HTML forms are usually very boring but
there's no reason that they can't be one
of the most creative aspects of your UI
and you don't even need a library like
material design to make that happen in
today's video we'll build an animated
login form from scratch with HTML and
CSS notice how it moves the label up
when an input field is focused and also
slides in a border underneath but when
it comes to the password we'll throw in
some JavaScript with spell to take
things to another level we'll write a
simple algorithm to analyze the password
strength then show the end user a
strength meter along with validation
errors based on the content of their
password in order to make all this
happen from scratch they learned about
CSS transforms and transition animations
pseudo elements like after box shadows
and gradients and even a little bit of
red X if you're new here like and
subscribe and if you like the format of
this video make sure to let me know what
you want to see next in the comments
let's start by taking a closer look at
what we're building today what we have
here is just a regular HTML form input
along with a label when the user focuses
in on a form input we translate the
label up along the y-axis and scale it
down a little bit this behavior was made
famous by material design but you can
easily implement it on your own with
just a few lines of CSS when the input
is focused we also animate in a border
from the left side but it's not handled
with a border it actually uses a CSS
pseudo element which we'll talk about
later
now our password field is really over
the top when the user starts typing it
animates this password meter based on
the strength of the password I'll show
you how to use a box shadow to create
this shudder like effect for each bar in
the meter in addition we'll also
validate different patterns in the
password string to show the user
specific validation errors and finally
we'll add a little button in the form
input so the user can see their password
text this tutorial is designed for you
to follow along step by step and you can
find the project's source code on github
well mostly be talking about HTML and
CSS but we'll use felt to you manage our
JavaScript and application state and if
you've never used smelt before don't
worry you're gonna love it it's super
intuitive and easy to learn to get
things started we'll head over to spelt
dev you'll see a command here that you
can run with NP X to create a new small
project go ahead and run these commands
from the terminal then open up your
project in vs code and we're ready to go
in the source directory you'll see a
file called
app guts felt this is where we'll be
writing all of our code for now you can
treat this file like a regular
HTML file we'll set up a script tag this
is where our JavaScript will go then a
style tag is where our CSS will go
everything outside of these tags will be
our main HTML markup towards the end of
the video you'll learn how spelt can
magically connect your JavaScript to
your HTML now one side note here is that
if you go into the public folder you'll
also see a global dot CSS file in my
demo I modified the body styles to have
a black background with white text now
back in our main app component we'll
start by setting up the mark-up for the
initial HTML form we have a main element
with a form element nested inside and
then inside that we have a div with a
class of field that is basically a
container for the input and label inside
of this div we'll add the actual form
input and we'll make sure to give it a
type of email after the input we'll add
the label and it's important that this
label comes after the input and I'll
tell you why that's important when we
get to the relevant CSS code then we'll
do the same exact thing for our password
field but give it a type of password if
you open up the app on localhost 5,000
you should have a basic form that looks
like this back in our code we'll start
by targeting in the form element I'm
going to be using a gray text color
throughout my Styles so I'm going to set
that up as a CSS variable here that'll
make it really easy to change the color
of the form if we decide to in the
future and then we'll set the max width
of the form to 500 pixels then we'll
define our field style which is
basically a container for the input and
label we'll give it a width of 100% and
then we'll change the position to
relative by default a div has static
positioning the difference here is very
subtle but the most important thing to
know is that when you use relative
positioning it means you can use
properties like top left bottom and
right to control where this elements
it's relative to its normal position
from there we'll give it a - pixel -
border on the bottom that uses our text
color variable then we'll provide a good
size margin here to make room for our
animations because I'm providing three
values here the margin will work like
this the top margin will be four REM the
left and right margins will be auto and
the bottom margin will be one REM 1r n
is equal to the root font size of the
HTML so if you have a font size of 16
pixels one REM is 16 pixels and then
we'll override a bunch of styles on the
input like the outline border overflow
and so on the input will basically just
sit inside the container while its
parent field class will hand
all of the fancy animation stuff now
because our input has a type of email it
will automatically be validated by the
browser we can actually target the
pseudo selectors of valid and invalid to
give the input text a different color
based on whether or not it's a valid
email address you should now have a form
that looks like this and as you can see
when you type your email address in it
goes from red to green when it becomes a
valid email and now we're ready to get
into the fun stuff let's look at how we
can make that border animation when a
form field is focused we'll do that by
targeting the after pseudo element on
the field many HTML elements like a div
have pseudo elements that you can target
in style after is like an invisible
element that comes after your div it
never appears in your HTML markup but if
you go into the browser's inspector
you'll see it listed there when you have
a style targeting it and in our case
we'll use it to display a border
underneath the field the advantage in
this case over a regular CSS border is
that we can use transforms to apply
fancy animations to it we'll give it a
position of relative and then a height
of 4 pixels a width of 100% and a purple
background now by default we want this
element to be hidden we can hide it with
a transform by setting the scale along
the x-axis to zero and the reason we use
scale X here and not just scale is
because we want to preserve the height
when we animate it back in now by
default the transform will happen right
in the middle of its position however we
want it to animate in from left to right
so we set the transform origin to 0%
however if you wanted to go from right
to left you could set the transform
origin to 100% now to animate it we
simply set up a transition that targets
the transform property we'll set it 4 or
500 milliseconds and give it an easing
timing function and then because it's
relatively positioned we'll set its top
property to 2 pixels that'll just move
it down slightly to cover the existing
border now in order to have an animation
we need some sort of state change we
want that state change to happen when
the input is focused however the actual
styles were changing are on the field
div CSS has a very useful Osito selector
called focus within when the inner input
is focused we can change styles on the
outer field div we can set the border
color to transparent and then we'll
target the after pseudo element and
we'll set its transform to scale x1 and
that will make it appear to slide in
from left to right at this point you
have a cool looking animated
order but the label isn't positioned
right at all so how do we create that
material design label animation in the
label class will first set AZ index of
negative 1 remember in the HTML the
label comes after the input so
technically it sits on top of it but
setting AZ index of negative 1 will make
the label as if it sits behind at the
actual form input will make its position
absolute which means it's relative
normally to the entire document or the
next relatively positioned element
further up in the tree which in our case
happens to be the field div which
contains the label next we'll use a
transform to move along the y axis and
with a negative value that will move it
up higher along the y axis
we'll set a transform origin of 0% and
then also set up a transition here to
animate it now just like our animated
border we can target the label by using
field focus within when it's focused
we'll go ahead and transform it with a
scale of 0.08 making it slightly smaller
and then we'll translate it further up
the y axis at this point your animation
should work but you'll notice when we
type into the form the label comes back
down into the form field covering up the
user's text and that's not going to work
this is why it's important that the
label comes after the input because it
allows us to target the input when it's
placeholder is not shown or in other
words when the user has typed something
into the form and we can use the plus
sign to target the next sibling that has
a class of label so this means the label
will be positioned in the right spot if
the field either has focus or if it has
text inside the input and now we're
ready to start building out our password
validation meter we'll go back into our
HTML markup and add a div with a class
of strength then inside that div we'll
have 4 spans each with a class of bar
and each with a unique class four bars
one two three and four then directly
below that we'll add an unordered list
with ap validation error messages now up
in our CSS we'll define the strength
class as a flexible row that has a
height of exactly 20 pixels and a width
of a hundred percent now each of the
bars inside this flexible row will have
a margin right of 5 pixels a height of
100% and a width of 25% so each
individual bar in the password meter
will take up exactly 25 percent of the
parents width now each individual bar
can be animated in or out with a little
shudder effect using a black shadow so
we'll set that up as a train
now and then our buck shadow will be
inset with an offset on the x-axis of
zero pixels and an offset of 20 pixels
on the y-axis the result of this code is
an inner shadow that covers up the
entire element because remember the
parent elements height is exactly 20
pixels and the offset Y here is exactly
20 pixels as well when we want to show
the colors inside one of these bars we
can simply set the block shadow to none
now each individual bar has its own
color gradient so for bar one we'll set
a background that's equal to a linear
gradient that moves from left to right
on the left side we'll have red and then
it will gradually transition to orange
red on the right side then we'll do the
same thing for all the other bars after
that where the color on the left side is
the color that ended on the right side
from the previous bar your demo at this
point should have four gray bars but if
you go back in your source code and call
Matt out the black shadow then you
should see your color gradient okay so
at this point everything we've done has
been just plain HTML CSS but now we're
going to make this app reactive and
interactive with spell the first thing
we'll do is go up into our script and
add a variable for strength as a number
that starts at zero and a second
variable validations which starts as an
empty array and the beauty of spelt is
that this is all you have to do to
create reactive State in your
application anytime the strength or
validations values change the component
will rerender to display the latest
values in our case we want the state to
change every time the user types into
the password form field and we'll do
that by running a function that
validates their password after each
input this function will take the event
as an argument and then we can get the
actual string value of the password by
calling event target value now to
validate the password we have four
different rules that we want to apply
and we can define those rules as an
array where each value in that array is
a boolean value that's true or false
whether or not the user has passed that
rule with their input so if the password
length is greater than 5 then we know
that the validation rule at index 0 has
been passed the next rule at index 1 in
the array performs a reg X search
regular expressions are pretty weird but
we have some pretty simple use cases
here this first rule will search the
string for any capital letters ranging
from A to Z if it doesn't find any
it's negative one so we know we have a
capital letter in the string if it's
greater than negative 1 our next
validation will search through the
digits of 0 to 9 to see if they have a
number in their password and the fourth
and final validation will look for a
series of special characters now at this
point we have an array of 4 boolean
values that will be updated every time
the user types into the form in
JavaScript we can calculate the total
strength of the password by adding up
these four boolean values assigning the
number 1 to each true value an easy way
to do that is with array reduce by
simply adding the accumulated value to
the current value giving us the sum of
all the values in the array that's
actually all the JavaScript code we need
at this point our next step is to bind
it to the actual HTML to use our
validate password function we need to go
down to our password input and listen to
the input event which we do with on and
spelt every time the user types into the
form the input event is fired and then
runs our validate password event handler
that'll update the state of the
application now we need to put that
state to use by binding it to our HTML
in spelt we can bind a class using this
class directive what this does is it
only applies the bar show class which
will remove that box-shadow when the
right side evaluates to true so we'll
show the first bar when the strength is
greater than 0 then we'll show the
second bar when it's greater than 1
greater than 2 3 and so on now below
that we either want to show a green
check mark or a red X depending on
whether or not that validation has been
passed we can look at each validation by
its index and then use a ternary
operator to display a check mark when
true or an ex when false and then we can
follow the same pattern for each
validation message at this point if you
open up your demo you should be able to
type into the password field and see it
reactively update the state and the UI
and each time the password goes stronger
it should show the password bar with a
shudder like animation now we've already
done a lot at this point but there is
one more thing I want to show you and
that's implementing a way for the user
to preview their password before
submitting it will go up into our
JavaScript and first add a new property
called show password then in our CSS
I'll create a new class here called
toggle password which just absolutely
positions a button so it is displayed in
the right side of the actual form input
itself from there we'll go into our HTML
and
below the label for the password will
add a span that has the class of
tolerable password there are a few
different ways we could implement this
but I think a kind of unique way to do
this is to have the user preview their
password by hovering over the actual
button itself as opposed to clicking on
it we can do that by listening to the
mouse enter event and then we'll pass an
anonymous function here that simply
toggles the show password property to
true and then on Mouse leave will toggle
the show password value back to false
then inside the actual button content
will use a ternary operator here to show
a different emoji based on the state of
show password in the final magic to
convert this from a password field to a
text field is to go up here to the input
type and where we have a static string
value for password we'll use a dynamic
ternary that changes it from password to
text based on the state of the
application and now at this point you
should be able to preview the password
value by simply hovering over the emoji
like I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things
up there if you want to see more svelte
content or have more project ideas make
sure to let me know in the comments and
if you want access to more advanced
content consider becoming a pro member
at fire ship IO thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one
[Music]